hey kevin how are you hi sugita how are
you
good i mean this must be a dream job for
you to talk about
nascar you're the chief the crew chief
you're the executive producer i mean
this is a dream come true i mean cars
must be a hobby for you
you know what they're not uh they're not
they're not they're not a hobby like i
i i've always loved cars you know just
but never
i'm not like i'm not mechanically
inclined i know nothing
about them you know i just i you know i
like driving fast when i can
uh and i do but uh this is a whole new
world nascar is such a different world
for me and it was
really exciting because i didn't know
that much about it and now i'm learning
more and more about it uh
it's it's crazy it's this whole universe
of it is
you know competitive teams and families
and going against each other and turning
on themselves and
so it's it's a great avenue for comedy
too and it's it's you know
it's just a great great uh experience
for me
yeah and it's great that nascar is
backing you up with the show the fact
that it's gonna be premiering right off
uh opening after daytona 500. uh what
will
fans get to experience through this show
you know
the insides it's it's it's it's you know
they're going to think it's so different
and there's elements of the show that
are so different because of
of the nature of nascar and the world
that i didn't know about and you know
being down on the track uh being you
know in the office and the pit crews and
this and that and watching the races and
uh but this it's also when you when it
comes down to it you see that it's a
it's a family it's like a workplace
comedy too so you you completely relate
to it
you get into the uh the relationships of
the of the the characters
and that's what it's all about you
really you get lost in it in a good way
you get lost in the in the world of
nascar
and it's it just it it just it works
really well i love that and then jillian
comes in
her character catherine comes in and
she's trying to modernize things
you know this is the world of
millennials uh how caught up are you
with social media and technology are you
are you pretty good at it no no no
no i'm not not even i'm not i can't even
i
i i don't understand you know i mean i'm
in it and i and i do it because i'm
realizing hey listen this is the way
you have to learn you have to go you
know it's like you know
it's i feel like i'm a baby who learned
to crawl and i'm like now i'm good here
i'm gonna stay here and i've been
crawling
my whole life and they're like we gotta
we gotta walk this
we're moving on so i have people help me
with everything
i do but i i don't i'm not i'm not great
at it
yeah i could totally bring that picture
what are you doing no i'm learning tick
tock i have two kids i'm trying to learn
i don't know dances it's tough it's
tough
i it got me thinking back to grown-ups
uh adam sandler bought you guys all
maseratis i remember that was like
a decade ago if you were to hit the
racetrack with your cr
your crew from grown-ups who would win
uh i
i i would say not chris rock chris rock
could not win
no he's not going to win because he just
doesn't you know
that's a tough one i think it would be
sandman and i'm not saying it because
the sandman did it all and he put it all
together
but spade doesn't have any energy really
he's got nothing he would be dead behind
the wheel
uh so i think i think a sandler is just
at a default would be the you know
i i would beat him but i had the energy
to do it and i know i could do it
it's just i know with my size over him
it may slow the card down a tad
and i think that that would be it i
think that would
it would be a what do they call it a
photo finish type thing yes
i'm so glad you're back i love the show
congratulations i can't wait for
everyone to see it
and thanks for bringing some comedy we
really need it right now so we really
appreciate it
thank you i really appreciate the
support